all right I'll get started I'm Andre
kuznia rukh director of document media
systems here all from I've been doing
this sort of stuff for a very long time
I have a lot of different mixed
responsibilities so you all might
interact with me in a lot of different
capacities but the 1i usually focus on
here at our tech conference is CDF I try
to be the central source of what's going
on in CDF I don't know everything about
the technology i try to know most about
it i try to get things fixed if things
are broken through all the different
teams responsible for it and I help set
policy for the kinds of rules and
licensing aspects that go along with it
I'd like to talk now about where we are
with it and what's new what's coming so
let's get started with that i should say
right off the bat that Mathematica 10 is
of course out the door you've all seen
it but it usually takes a little while
for CDF player to catch up it's taking a
little bit longer this time because
we've got quite a large stack of things
to work through with a lot of different
projects in the case of CDF player we
are making a major change in how we put
it out into the world it used to be that
we had two separate products that were
called player player pro and CDF player
separate from each other where our plan
now is to build them together and player
pro becomes an activation of CDF players
so I think lots of people have been
wanting that so that's our direction
going forward let me just reiterate what
we did with version 9 we introduced
enterprise CDF I think there's still
always a lot of conversation to be had
about that I'm a good person to work
with on it but our sales people also are
the good entry point for that and they
bring questions to me we improved our
sandboxing inverse
9 and of course carrying forward in
version 10 HTML export in Mathematica
for version 9 included embedded CDF so
that was a nice add-on there we added a
preview mode in version 9 so when you're
developing content that you plan to put
out a CDF you can you can look at it in
this file cdf preview choice here
whether you're looking at it for
distribution as free CD f or enterprise
see if it gives you a way to test what
you're doing we did a few little
deployment wizard updates we added send
mail to enterprise cdf and we extended
input field support a little bit for
enterprise cdf to include special
functions and added our link support for
enterprise going forward with version 10
i think at the last conference i
mentioned these things and these are
still plan so i'll go through them in a
little more detail and i can talk about
the plugin issues in the context of
mathematica which you all have because
the plugin is the same technology
whether it's coming from a thematic ax
or coming from cdf player alright so but
the first thing separate from a plug-in
is that we have the cdf deploy function
which a number of you have been using to
do development where if you are doing
application development and you've you
know put a lot of material together in a
notebook it's your ide right it's your
scripting environment whatever you like
it to be and you are on a regular basis
developing or deploying CDF's you don't
want to necessarily do that manually
through the menu we have the cdf deploy
function for that purpose and previously
it was a little unclear on how to pick
up the enterprise licensing behaviors in
version 10 that's what it defaults to in
other words whatever your license level
is is what you get when you do
cdf deploy so i just want to make that
point clear and I'm sure that's very
useful to a lot of you another feature
of the plug-in now going back to that
that's new is web scaling so for years
now it's been an issue that you could
not get your CD F to match when you
magnified your window but now that just
works the thing to be clear about with
that is that to get that behavior you do
have to export your CDF with version 10
it's not the CDF player and the plug-in
is not just going to magically pick that
up for you it's you have to go back to
the CD s use deployed and run those
through version 10 to get that another
nice feature that's available in the 10
plug-in is accessing parameters from the
Dom in other words from the the model
that describes everything in the HTML to
the browser so the the function for that
is or the feature the way to access that
is through this argument string plugin
parameters to current value and in your
CEF that you deploy you essentially can
run a dynamic on that to get a constant
result of this the different parameters
that might have been defined in the page
including other kinds of data so anyway
to explain where those parameters are
supposed to be coming from i'm just
showing here in the cell I'll pass this
information along with my talk if you're
just using the embed tag without using
our JavaScript it's just you know
standard parameter settings in the case
of our JavaScript it's an additional
list that you had to wear the embedded
CDF is being called in the code and
let's see if any of these other ones are
working this one seems to be working
so the point here is that this this box
right here the square box is coming from
a CDF it's the same CDF but every time
I'm pushing these buttons here I'm
resetting the parameter value for what
color to pull into it and you you're
essentially using the method that you
rewrite your HTML on the fly to pass
those parameters through because you're
rewriting the setting of those
parameters for the embed code for the
CDF it's pretty much the standard way
these things are done like when you run
forms or anything else in the case of
this example there's JavaScript that is
being run to redefine that expression
the example I was having trouble with is
more simple than that and I maybe I did
something wrong when I set it up so let
me go to one of these other older
examples I've had of that feature this
theme selector so same thing here that
it's resetting the entire page by
pulling in different pictures it's not
changing the CDF it's just resetting
parameters for the CDF which changed the
color in this plot ok let's jump forward
another idea that has sort of come
together this year and that I think is
worth discussing now because of the way
that we build our products is this
notion of a what I call a portable CD f
layout and the idea there is that if
you're developing the application and
you really don't like having your
customer let's say or the person you're
building it for have to download
something to install it's possible to
give them an entire CDF application
layout and have it just run on their
system and that's now true for windows
as well that had been true in the past
for our McIntosh bills because apples
Apple
stations are always generally self
contained in the case of Windows that's
true now as well so things like fonts
and all the other dll's for math link
etc are all contained in the application
directory so it's possible to actually
zip up say both a Windows and Mac
version of CDF player which is what I've
done here in this layout and so when
somebody unzips what you've given them
they could essentially just use a this
is a java file I had written it's a
simple thing that looks for what
platform Iran and opens the correct
player and opens the first CDF in the
list of file so in this case I have a
directory of files which are the max CDF
player and the windows CD f player and a
CDF file this CDF file is just one
simple one but it could be the the CDF
file you want people to be exposed to
first and you can have a whole chain of
CDF files in here and dot n files and
whatever else that support your
application and by double-clicking the
jar file it just starts up the
appropriate player and starts up that
CDF file that you want them to see when
it first opens now in the case that this
is based on version 9 and one of the
features that word we're taking care of
her version 10 is if you launch a CDF by
double clicking on it or dragging it to
the app it will repress the welcome
screen in this case you'll see that it
does give it that so if this were now in
version 10 what you would see open is
just that CDF file so this is the
starting point for for you to work with
now I do happen to have CDF player and I
do happen to have mathematic on my
machine but i have tested this on clean
machines that have never had any of our
products installed and it does work so
it's something that you can check in on
through our sales team or support team
and I can help get that configured for
people I've even mapped out a little
wizard for building this zip
architecture that pulls the applications
off of our packet server so conceivably
you just walk through the wizard push a
few buttons it builds it for you go away
get some coffee come back and everything
will be zipped up for you okay and new
details for our version 10 base CDF
player free CDF will support up to four
cores enterprise CD f up to 16 cores
it's been a bit buggy in the past we
will have input field copy and paste
working cleanly as I just mentioned
repressing the welcome screen when
opening files directly which i think is
pretty important for people delivering
applications and then because we are
building everything together as the same
app you know pro and CDF player we're
not in fact it's essentially Mathematica
because we're not sweating the details
about footprint we used to you know
years back it was sort of a concern it's
like well you know it's getting to be
300 400 megabytes we better sweat that
nobody cares anymore really you know if
the thing is about that size are bigger
it's fine and that's probably where it
will arrive at and so that means
connected connectivity for all the
different types that we support will
just be consistent everywhere we
shouldn't see any more problems with
that I want to talk about cloud CDF
because as I mentioned you know the
issues of plug-in viability are a
concern and really the only appropriate
way forward is to be working with cloud
deployments so I think you know cloud
has been the message
of this conference and you've probably
seen a lot of different demos of things
I just want to summarize more than
anything of what's there and show them
quickly so in the case of you know
working from your desktop you can
essentially deploy straight from there
so if you're you know putting together
an interactive object and run cloud
deploy on that you know object that
you've defined you end up with this uri
that takes you straight to that object
in the cloud I thought maybe I was
making that public again you've probably
seen a lot of people do this here at the
conference and logging in I'm not quite
sure mine ended up having to do that
that's right so anyway here's the cdf
living in the cloud and i think you saw
Steve and demo that as well it's pretty
reasonable as an experience it's it's it
does i think what it should then you
know you could just as well be creating
that in your cloud account and you know
this is the same thing you know as if i
were developing it right now here you
know with the code for it should be
available well there it is so you know i
can share from here if i choose to and
i'll just go through that quickly
so you know so essentially you can work
through file access set settings that we
have in the cloud so in this file tab
here and when you choose access you can
pick people to collaborate with so
you're putting emails in here and they
have access to this thing that you've
developed so in in that way this becomes
a bridge you know that what you put in
the cloud is the bridge between you and
your co-workers or collaborators but
other options include embedding it as an
object on a server somewhere so if you
choose to deploy embeddable content
you're given a lot of choices to work
with here not all of them are active the
CDF plugin one is still under
development but if we say embeddable web
content well this one cloud CDF yeah all
right that's probably the cleanest one
to point out you know you asked to
generate the script and you're given a
code blob to copy and paste into your
HTML so let me just show that real fast
so I've done that with this HTML page
and this is the embedded object I think
we still have to do a little work with
controlling margins I didn't have much
luck with that but everything that's
here is branded going forward in future
there will be methods to white label
this but it's the same object it's it's
you know on a separate server and the
code for that can't pull that file up
but it's straightforward enough that you
could use em bed code as well on your
desktop to generate that so for example
you get a result like this you know when
you say embed code of cloud deploy of
that object and again it's the same
little code blob right here that
supports what you just saw in that page
yep correct and and so that's again the
main point of that is to get away from
the issues of most modern browsers
wanting to put a security interface on
top of any plugin or ultimately
eliminating support for the Netscape
plug-in architecture which is what our
technologies based on which most plugins
are now Google develop their pepper
plug-in which architecture which has
allowed Adobe to at least make flash and
PDF plugins work in chrome going into
the future but most other companies are
moving away from plugins that said the
plug-in will still give you speed and
efficiency so that's why we're working
out the cloud option for making that
another way to embed CDF from the work
you do through the cloud you could
conceivably you know use the plug-in if
it's available to the client side and
get very fast interactivity and if it
isn't available then it can go back to
the cloud version ok and so I'll talk
real quickly about our plans for future
so you've been hearing about mobile that
is something we are still pushing hard
on and we are making or we can make an
SDK available for iPad but it's not
documented well and it's one of those
things where you really have to want it
we have to really want to give it to you
so it's a conversation the the CDF
player and iPad is still coming but the
a Wolfram cloud app for mobile devices
is the thing we're focused on right now
and that is a good way to access a lot
of your content and it's it's
essentially more portable because it's
you know the kind of thing that we can
easily put together for most all mobile
devices we're looking forward our
head to a certificate based security
authorization system so you don't have
to see that little dynamics warning
every time you are running something
that is more than just a very simple
manipulate and it allows us to develop a
public signing mechanism so you know we
can interact with you if you need
something to be secured through our
certificate system we set it up and it
just works for all of your customers
that way or all of your clients it also
is the first step in allowing us to make
CDF the default format for all Wolfram
products and it gives some pretty good
potential for DRM as well we can we do
believe we can develop a DRM platform on
that and then finally a sort of like
what I just described as our as that
portable CD f solution we do aim to have
a CDF archive format which is
essentially a zip file that is
recognizable as a CDF so your entire
application can be built in you know
multi file layout that is then saved as
a CDF and you can deliver that to people
and it will open as a CDF in any Wolfram
product including the players then last
point here for as far as resources go we
did develop a new training course that
pulls together a lot of the information
we've pulled together on our website and
then some in terms of developing CDF's
and particularly you know Harry advanced
cases I maybe some of you took that we
offered that at just ahead of the
conference and we've got these website
updates on our various links that point
to resources and other thing so that's
it for me